our main story tonight concerns the fact
that one of America's most sacred annual
traditions is upon us
everything comes down to this
[Music]
March is all
holy yes March is on a queue
February and I'll see you in hell it's
not o'clock
March Madness the year's biggest college
tournament starts on Tuesday and the
entire nation will be watching which
means big big money
March Madness now brings in over a
billion dollars in TV ad revenue a
billion dollars that's more than the
Super Bowl it's almost more than the
entire NFL postseason combined and that
might seem like a lot until you consider
the number of ads they managed to pack
in sponsored by Lexus AT&T at the half
is presented by AT&T our game is brought
to you in HD TV by HP Coke Zero presents
real fans of NCAA March Madness pretty
soon the only thing left a sponsor will
be the sponsorships themselves and now
Pepsi presents a Geico look at the
bisko's Toyota moment of the game
brought to you by Taco Bell you should
know everything about this tournament is
branded even the famous moment where
players cut down the net Warner ladder
proud to donate to the general
scholarship fund of every school in this
year's final for Werner the official
letter of the NCAA
championships are you kidding me
a Werner latter look as a ladder
enthusiast I can tell you right now well
as a pure unless you want a broken
back are back in which case by all means
go with Werner but you'd be better off
slapping on a pair of stilts and trying
to balance on a yoga ball i'ma do waltz
man of course idiot there there is
nothing inherently wrong with a sporting
tournament making huge amounts of money
but there is something slightly
troubling about a billion dollar sports
enterprise where the athletes are not
paid a penny because they aren't and as
the head of the NCAA Mark Emmett will
tell you they don't want that to change
and there's not even a salary to debate
they're not employees they're students
the fact is they're not employees
they're student-athletes I can't say
often enough obviously that student
athletes are students they're not
employees the only other people who say
they're not employees that much of
people who run illegal sweatshops out of
their basements oh they're not employees
it's a summer camp where they make the
same t-shirt over and over again
thousands of times it's summer fun
year-round and the problem is when you
don't pay people there are consequences
one of the players who climbed the
sponsored ladder last year was Shabazz
Napier who happened to let slip a
startling fact after one of the games
sometimes like I said is hungry nights I
don't I'm not able to eat in ice but I
still gotta pay up too much you know I'm
starving
that's insane hunger games should take
place annually in a dystopian future not
every March sponsored by coca-cola on
CBS the n-c-double-a insists that
student athletes cannot be paid because
they're amateurs and thought they've
slightly softened their rules on food
among other things in the last year they
still exercised a ridiculous amount of
control over players before they're
allowed to compete athletes have to sign
this form saying that they are amateurs
they give up any compensation for
playing and promise to abide by all the
rules in this 440 page manual a 400 odd
page manual of rules the only other
thing that has that many Finnick
little rules would be a sex party at Wes
Anderson's house guests are required to
wear lingerie of only a pre-war
Andalusian vintage fellatio may only be
accompanied by music from the kinks and
early Cat Stevens and condoms shall be
found nestled inside a small diorama of
the sinking of the Lusitania
now everybody the emcee rulebook is not
just for show as a New Mexico player
discovered a few years back a discount
on a hotel ballroom is the impermissible
benefit and se a minor violation their
cost of all fin to be suspended yes
that's right he was suspended for
unwittingly receiving a two hundred and
fifty dollar discount on a ballroom for
his 21st birthday party and by the way a
discounted ballroom are we absolutely
sure he was turning 21 and not
celebrating his 40th wedding anniversary
with his lovely wife Marion because that
would make more sense but the point is
some rule enforcement's go from the
petty to the downright heartless the
late Rick Majerus when he was at Utah I
had one of his players who lost one of
his parents and he took him to lunch
before putting him on a plane to send
him home and the n-c-double-a said that
was a violation because you can't give
an athlete something you don't give
another student oh sure I'll get that if
you show one player basic human decency
you have to show everyone basic human
decency nobody wants that and to be fair
to be fair the n-c-double-a claimed that
while student athletes are not being
paid they are being compensated with
something incredibly valuable we provide
them with remarkable opportunities to
get an education at the finest
universities on earth that's American
universities and colleges yes
athletes are paid in an education the
only currency more difficult to spend
than Bitcoin and a four-year education
is undeniably valuable assuming that one
you don't get hurt and lose your
scholarship which can happen and to that
you have time to study because if you're
a student athlete playing top-level
basketball or football that can be
difficult
listen to current NFL player Richard
Sherman reminisce about his college days
you wake up in the morning you have
weights at this time then after weights
you go to class and after class you go
you go maybe try to grab you a quick
bite to eat then after you get your
quick bite to eat you go straight to
meetings and after meetings you got
practice and after practice you got to
try to get all the work done you you had
throughout the day I would love for for
a regular student to have a
student-athletes scheduled during the
season for just just one quarter or one
semester and and show me how you balance
that he's right paying top college
athletes with an education is sort of
like telling a full-time nurse there's
no salary for this job we're just going
to be giving you free trumpet lessons
which you'll be too busy to do but if
you don't learn to play the trumpet
you're fires I think that sounds fair
and the education athletes do get is
sometimes insultingly watered down last
year an investigation revealed that the
university of north carolina had for
years held fraudulent so-called paper
classes that boosted athletes grades
football basketball players they would
be enrolled steered - and enrolled in a
paper class in african-american studies
so we could have a football player who
in the spring might have a GPA of 1.4
but in the summertime we put them in
three paper classes and we get a a a -
and lo and behold he's academically
eligible to play football in the fall
and that's how the system worked ok
let's not pretend that isn't something
offensive about an African American
Studies course being an easy major at
that school I just took this class
investigating these social political and
cultural complexities inherent to the
black American experience it'll be a
breeze because many student athletes at
UNC also left with an unusual language
credit what language did you study
Swahili Swahili yes that come in handy
since you're graduating
No what language did you take I took
Swahili Swahili yes
do you speak Swahili a little bit as of
right now now encouraging black student
athletes to take Swahili
courses is the kind of institutional
prejudice which might well turn up in
one of their African American Studies
courses so let's recap student athletes
don't get paid and sometimes don't even
get educated but what they do get is the
chance to learn from coaches who will
take them under their wing and provide
them with life lessons and valuable
guidance that is now
now that that is inspirational someone
to grip someone should really put that
on a cat poster
[Applause]
let's lift your spirits this mystery is
happening huge money is being made and
not just while they're students because
sometimes the NCAA makes money off
players years afterwards case in point a
few years ago the n-c-double-a proudly
license this video game a game who's
selling point was authenticity crowd the
noise the cheerleaders power the
intensity of the game the passion of the
game it's all about authenticity the
level of authenticity that we go to is
extremely deep to be honest I thought
the only people that obsessed with how
authentic something was like that were
people from San Diego talking about
Mexican food but I get it Kendall but
there are avocados everywhere now okay
we've all got them now in fact that game
was so authentic it created a bit of an
awkward moment for ed O'Bannon a former
UCLA star player who currently works in
a car dealership in Las Vegas I was with
a friend and he said that his son at a
video game with me in it hey you want to
go check it out you know so yeah of
course left-handed height weight skin
color everything it was I'm thinking to
myself wow they got me on the video game
and while his kid was playing he almost
whispers it in my ears like you know the
crazy thing about this is you didn't get
paid okay but first of all I don't know
who that kid was but that's a dick move
hey dad's pretty crazy how you got
nothing for this right
must be pretty humiliating right ed
about you not getting any money but they
said it's pretty annoying right ed are
you annoyed ed are you annoyed right now
ed is it annoying to you Ed actually
they actually don't make that game
anymore
in part because ed O'Bannon sued the
NCAA over their rules on compensating
athletes and won the NCAA is currently
appealing that decision which would
allow players to be paid partly because
as they often claim schools could barely
afford it 14 schools out of the 1,100
last year actually had positive cash
flow on of intercollegiate athletics
it's anything but a money-making
proposition for universities and
colleges exactly we have sports for the
same reason Mariah Carey has an acting
career
God knows it's not to make a profit it's
for the love of the game okay that's the
principle now he's not he's not wrong
that many departments barely break even
although that's a little misleading
because for the schools that generate
most of the money those losses are
sometimes by design profits are what's
left when you account for expenses they
can come up with an awful lot of
expenses an awful lot of salaries they
find them a ton of ways to spend that's
true in keeping with their nonprofit
status some schools spend money to make
it look like they're not making too much
money it's like when your rich friend
buys diesel jeans that already have
holes in them
come on Braden we all know that you can
afford to have warm knees you're not
fooling anyone B and when and when rich
schools do this to move money around not
so rich schools end up getting into an
arms race to compete it's one of the
reasons why the ten largest football
stadiums in the country belong to
colleges in fact the University of
Michigan has claimed that on game days
their stadium is the fourth largest city
in the state of Michigan and
incidentally also the one with the
fewest rusted out auto plants now run by
raccoon so
they're doing their best but but
stadiums are just the beginning
Alabama made an MTV Cribs style video
showing off their ludicrously opulent
football facilities one of the really
the best features I think of the locker
room is the hydrotherapy area we have in
there a hot tub and a cold tub and I
really I used the term tub but really
they're their pools okay I never thought
I'd say this but Alabama stop showing
off your ostentatious wealth okay and
the crazy thing is it is not just
buildings that school spends money on
Mississippi State coach Dan Mullen was
just given a raise pushing his salary to
four million dollars a year seven
million dollars a year for the next
eight years that's Alabama coach Nick
Saban's New Deal University of Kentucky
announced a fifty two million dollars
seven-year contract extension with head
basketball coach John Calipari now
before you get too shocked remember
America has a long proud history of
paying aging white men unconscionable
amounts of money for screaming at people
so there's precedence as I'm saying
there's precedent there but all this
makes it even harder to swallow when
some coaches like Clemson's Dabo Swinney
a man who makes over three million
dollars a year insists that his players
not get paid for paying players
professionalizing
college athletics that's where you lose
me you know I'll go do something else
because
you know there's enough entitlement on
this world as it is now like if you find
that infuriating you might like to know
that Dabo Swinney is an anagram for
soybean wind which i think is fitting
because he seems as pleasant as an
edamame fart and the fact and it's a
fact that his name is an anagram for
soybean wind is not relevant to this
discussion but I thought it was worth
mentioning because it feels like
something he'd be annoyed by and would
not want people to know on a wide basis
hashtag Sweeney has trademarked his name
for use on shirts because he's allowed
to do that the n-c-double-a manual
explicitly states coaches are free to
pursue endorsement or consultation
contracts and players are acutely aware
of this discrepancy his former
University of Michigan basketball start
Jalen Rose the revenue stream for
coaches people underestimate you get
paid from the school do you get paid
from camps did you pay from a payroll
company have a TV deal you have your
radio show that's five revenue strange
for the coach so when I come into
practice and I miss a couple of shots
and I dribble it off my foot and coach
said Jana what's going on with you
what's going on me my mother likes about
to get cut off that's my problem
that makes sense sometimes it must be
tough to focus on your lights out
shooting when your mother's lights are
literally going out and if you're
thinking well they'll all get rich when
they become professional athletes that's
true in a fractional number of cases
because less than two percent of college
basketball and football players go pro
so if you're an athlete who dreams of
being a Viking or a wizard you probably
have about the same chance of becoming
an actual Viking or an actual visit
and all of this assumes that they
managed to stay healthy because if they
get injured a whole host of other
problems can emerge fun fact the very
first executive director of the NCAA
stated that he crafted the term
student-athlete in the 1950s explicitly
to avoid workers comp for injured
athletes and 60 years later that term is
still working kyle hardrick was so good
that Oklahoma offered him a basketball
scholarship in ninth grade but after a
knee injury during practice his freshman
year he lost his scholarship and with
medical bills piling up he couldn't
afford to stay in school if it was
workman's comp my son would have been
taking care of for the rest of his life
he would have been able to finish his
college to be fair he was promised in
education and he got one a first-class
education in how little school sometimes
give a about their student athletes
this whole system seems fundamentally
flawed and yet the NCAA constantly
insists there is no way athletes can be
paid even a nominal amount because the
notion of converting a student to a paid
employee is something that is utterly
antithetical to the whole principle of
intercollegiate athletics it completely
changes the entire notion of what
college sports is all about you know
what I think you might be right if
college sports is all about exploiting
people then yes paying athletes would
absolutely change the entire notion of
what college sports are all about and
look look no one is saying they need to
be paid
for hundreds of thousands or the same
amount or even that every school needs
to pay every athlete but to pay everyone
zero when the kids selling their jersey
at the campus bookstore gets $10 an hour
seems a little bit strange and if it
truly is all about the romance of
amateurism that's fine give up the
sponsorships and the TV deals stop
paying the coaches and have teams run by
an asthmatic anthropology professor with
a whistle but if you are if you're gonna
change nothing at least be honest about
the business you're engaged in feel free
to bring back your video games but in
the spirit of all thank T City that
seems to matter so much to you make them
a little more accurate rated E for
exploitative from LWT Sports March set
is 2015 the most authentic college
basketball game of all time because any
game can give you the excitement of
college athletics but that's only about
2% of your week for the first time
you'll get to experience the other 98%
you'll get to enjoy all the fun of being
screamed at by a middle-aged millionaire
while living in constant fear of losing
your scholarship being from a
career-ending injury accidentally
accepting a free lunch when you're
hungry or directly profiting in any way
from the value of your work because
making money is utterly antithetical to
the whole principle of collegiate
athletics but don't take it from us take
it from the unwilling star of EA's NCAA
basketball Oh 9 and O'Bannon this game
is every bit as a real thing that you
played your own player and enjoy not
that a student athlete experience begins
our game puts just as much emphasis on
an education as a real n-c-double-a
division 1 school does are you ready for
your Swahili exam
congratulations students you speak
Swahili now back to the gym home it's
the most authentic college game of all
time as another unpaid star of NCAA
basketball o9 gym and row
will attest yeah that's pretty much what
it's like and this year if you play L WT
s n-c-double-a March sadness you can
play in two new modes coach mode which
consists mostly it's screaming at
eighteen year olds or you can choose
school administrator mode where your
only job is speak around how to somehow
remain a non-profit you want a stadium
across from yours idiom how about a
rocket ship but be careful because if
you use a penny of that money to pay
your players game over the point is no
matter which mode you choose you're
guaranteed all the joy of top level
college athletics March sadness 2015 LWT
sports it's an exchange this game is
some
you